going on a mountain and being in that
perilous situation is kind of one of
those things where you think who you
want to bring with you which one of your
characters from your previous work would
you want to take up on the mountain to
help you get down actually I can think
of one straightaway I would take Jim
Cameron because Jim Cameron would know
exactly been in all of those situations
himself before anyone that you played
that you would want to like a character
from no chance yeah so great tell me
about the going against the elements for
all of us for the whole crew incredible
Canadian crew absolutely extraordinary
people who could not have done it
without for sure but going through the
ice you know I was never meant to go
through the ice they had decided that my
stunt double Jeanine was absolutely
gonna do it and I remember just thinking
damn it I want to you know what is my
thing like I do water and ice was they
had submerged a large barrel that was
kind of little deeper than like than a
hot tub under the water and the water
was just cold but I turned to Hanny and
I just said you have to let me do this
because you can't get the shots that I
know that you want him to have in the
studio keep telling me I can't put
Caitlin the thing I was like okay watch
I just got in I was like right I'm doing
it and I remember that day it was tough
I mean you know Kate was a G because we
weren't in a heated room it was freezing
and she's soaking and then you know I
had to try and pull her out you know ten
years younger than me was just like I'll
do it I was like not have to do this I
have to let Kate go down there you know
by that stages were in filming like
every experience that we went through we
kind of like we're not in green-screen
this is really happening
really gah everyone you know and I
remember pulling around we did it a
couple of days and it was a round of
applause it was great
[Music]
you